Hi. Hi, Rain Wilson. Hi, Angela. Hi, Jenna. Hi, office ladies. Thanks for joining us. Yeah. And you're probably wearing your Seattle Seahawks hat. I'm representing. Yeah. Also, I haven't taken a shower yet, so my hair is matted. I wasn't sure if we were recording video, like for social media purposes or whatever. So we're not. No worries. Your bedhead is safe with us. Excellent. It's good to see you guys remotely. You look great. Do you have a Michael Scarn threat level midnight poster over your shoulder?
嗨。嗨，雷恩·威尔逊。嗨，安吉拉。嗨，珍娜。嗨，办公室女士们。谢谢你们加入我们。对啊。你可能还戴着西雅图海鹰队的帽子呢。我有代表出镜。对。还有，我还没洗头，所以头发都黏在一起了。我之前不确定我们是不是在录视频，比如为了社交媒体什么的。所以我们没有录视频。别担心。你的睡乱头在我们这很安全。太棒了。很高兴通过远程见到你们。你们看起来气色真好。你肩膀后面是不是贴着一张迈克尔·斯卡恩的“威胁级别：午夜”的海报？
I do, yes. It's one of my few kind of office memorabilias. I've just got a Michael Scarn poster. Yeah, I probably hang it. It looks signed. No, it's not signed. I suppose I could get it signed. I know the guy, Steve Correll,
是的，没错。这是我为数不多的办公室纪念品之一。我只有一张迈克尔·斯卡恩的海报。对啊，我可能会把它挂起来。看起来像是签过名的。不，没有签名。我想我可以弄个签名上去。我认识那家伙，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，
who played Michael Scarn. So I suppose I could get it signed. It's very cool. Even that Krasinski fellow, although he's kind of busy in New York. Goldface. He's not. not signing it. Golden face? Is that his name? Golden face. Yeah. I think I could probably talk to his
他饰演了迈克尔·斯卡恩。所以我想我可以弄个签名。这太酷了。还有那个卡拉辛斯基老兄，虽然他在纽约挺忙的。金面人。他没，他没签名。金面人？那是他的名字吗？金面人。对。我想我大概可以去跟他的
publicist's manager and see about getting a signature. Good luck with that. What's going on? What are we talking about? What's happening? What's happening with Office Ladies? It's been a long time since I've been on the show. You guys, congratulations on the success and everything you're doing and your media empire. It's beautiful. Thank you, Ray. Last time you were on Office Ladies, it was because I recorded you from the back of my car after we had lunch. So thank you for that. It was about food. It was about food. Yes. Now we're doing something special on Fridays. We do it once a month. It's called Friday Chit Chat. I'm so happy to be here, although you do kind of need a theme song for Friday Chit Chat. You think, Chit Chat. I feel like Ed Helms could write a really good Friday Chit Chat.
公关经理谈谈，看看能不能搞到一个签名。祝你好运。怎么回事？我们在聊什么？发生什么事了？“办公室女士”最近怎么样？我好久没上这个节目了。大家，祝贺你们取得成功以及你们正在做的一切，还有你们的媒体帝国。这太棒了。谢谢你，雷恩。你上一次来“办公室女士”还是因为我吃完午饭后在车后座录了你。所以谢谢你。那次是关于食物的。那是关于食物的。没错。现在我们在周五做一些特别的内容。我们一个月做一次。叫做“周五闲聊”。我很高兴能来到这里，虽然你们确实需要一首“周五闲聊”的主题曲。你想想，闲聊。我觉得艾德·海姆斯能写出一首非常棒的“周五闲聊”主题曲。
You are not wrong. That would be amazing. We should reach out to Ed. Let's get him on that. Well, here's how it works. We put a call to action to our fans out there who love office ladies. And we just said, what do you want us to chit-chat about? And they send in suggestions and we've got a great one this week. Jenna. Yes. Jenna, I hate to break it to you.
你没说错。那太棒了。我们应该联系一下艾德。让他来弄这个。好吧，它是这样的。我们向那些热爱“办公室女士”的粉丝们发出了号召。我们只是问，你们想让我们闲聊些什么？然后他们发来了建议，我们这周有一个非常棒的建议。珍娜。对。珍娜，我很不想打击你。
No one listens to this show. Oh, no. They don't. You don't have fans. Rain, that's AI bots or something. No one listens to office ladies. Well, this suggestion, Rain, we do. This is coming from.
没人听这个节目。哦，不。他们才不听呢。你们没有粉丝。雷恩，那是AI机器人什么的。没人听“办公室女士”。好吧，这个建议，雷恩，我们有。这是来自。
Jenna F. and Angela K from Los Angeles. Wow. I'd love to hear from Jenna F and Angela K. Jenna F and Angela K write in a lot. They're big fans. Okay, here is our chit-chat suggestion of the week. It comes from Audrey W. Audrey says, I've seen posts about which office character would you rather be stuck camping with. So I was wondering, who would you like to be stuck camping with for three days and why? Well, that's a great question.
来自洛杉矶的珍娜·F和安吉拉·K。哇。我很想听听珍娜·F和安吉拉·K的意见。珍娜·F和安吉拉·K经常写信来。她们是超级粉丝。好吧，这是我们本周的闲聊建议。它来自奥黛丽·W。奥黛丽说，我看到过一些帖子讨论你会愿意和哪个办公室角色一起被困在露营地。所以我想知道，你愿意和谁一起被困在露营地三天，为什么？嗯，这真是个好问题。
I mean, there's so many different ways you could go. I have a request. I would like us to say which office character we want to be stuck camping with and then which of us in real life we want to be stuck camping with. I like where you're going with this. I like where you're going. I definitely know which office character would be the most fun. And I'm a little bit biased because immediately as you read the question, I was like, oh, there's an episode here. And that would be Dwight and Andy camping together or being forced to camp together
我的意思是，你可以有很多不同的选择。我有个请求。我希望我们先说出想和哪个办公室角色一起被困在露营地，然后再说现实生活中我们想和谁一起被困在露营地。我喜欢你的思路。我喜欢你的思路。我绝对知道哪个办公室角色会最有趣。我有点偏心，因为当你读到这个问题时，我脑子里立刻就冒出一个想法，这里可以拍一集。那就是德怀特和安迪一起露营，或者被迫一起露营，
and just total opposites on the campground. I don't know if that's what the question was. I just kind of put myself in Dwight's shoes. But I think it would be so much fun because Andy would have like the perfect tent from like LL Bean, you know, and his stove and like a solar panel and like a drone that, you know, can bring in food. And he'd have a freeze-dried ramen and pot stickers and gourmet food. And then Dwight would just have like a loincloth and a knife and like a tent made out of a Buffalo hide or something like that. That would be such a good episode, don't you think? It would.
而在露营地上他们俩完全是截然相反的类型。我不知道这是否就是问题的本意。我只是代入了德怀特的角色。但我认为这会非常有趣，因为安迪会带着完美的帐篷，比如来自LL Bean的帐篷，你知道的，还有他的炉子、太阳能电池板以及一架可以送食物来的无人机。他会有冻干拉面、锅贴和美食。而德怀特可能只有一条遮阴布、一把刀以及一个用野牛皮或类似东西搭成的帐篷。那会是一集非常精彩的节目，你不觉得吗？确实如此。
And I feel like Andy would make up a campfire song and it's like the whole thing. He'd have brought a travel banjo. Yeah. And he would have a smore. kit that was like a really high-end R-E-I-Somor's kit. Oh, and tons of sunscreen. He'd have tons of sunscreen that's probably harmful to the environment, just like spraying it all over.
而且我觉得安迪会创作一首营火歌，而且还会搞得很隆重。他会带一个旅行班卓琴。对。他会带一个S'more棉花糖夹心饼干套装，那是一种非常高端的REI S'more套装。哦，还有大量的防晒霜。他会有大量的防晒霜，可能对环境有害的那种，就在到处乱喷。
For three days, these guys. And he'd have an elevated tent that like the bottom inflated and brought them off the ground. But I think that an episode with Dwight and Andy camping would be, we kind of had that with Survivor Man with Dwight and Michael, but. Michael, yeah. I think that would be really fun to watch the opposites. And then Dwight goes and, you know, kills a fawn with a hunting knife. And like Andy's peaking.
这两家伙要待三天。他还会有一个高架帐篷，底部充气，让他们离开地面。但我认为德怀特和安迪一起露营的那一集会是……我们在“求生专家”那一集里德怀特和迈克尔有过类似的经历，但是。迈克尔，对。我觉得看这两个对立面会非常有趣。然后德怀特去用猎刀杀了一只小鹿。而安迪在偷看。
He's peaking in the woods. I would watch that episode. Would you as Rain Wilson want to go camping with Dwight or Andy? Well, Dwight would definitely be more of an adventure. But since I'm a little bit more of the indoor type, I like some camping sometimes. But I think that Andy would be great. It's just entertainment, technology, comfort. I'm going to go straight up with Andy.
他在树林里偷看。我会看那一集的。作为雷恩·威尔逊，你想和德怀特还是安迪去露营？嗯，德怀特绝对会带来更多冒险。但由于我更偏向室内型的人，虽然我偶尔也喜欢露营。但我认为安迪会是个不错的选择。只有娱乐、科技、舒适。我直接选安迪。
Final answer. Andy Bernard, final answer. Andy on both Dwight and Rain. Yeah. What about you, Ms. Fisher? What about me? I thought about this. I really did.
最后答案。安迪·伯纳德，最后答案。安迪，无论是德怀特还是雷恩。对。你呢，费舍尔女士？我呢？我想过这个。我真的想过。
And I thought about who I don't want to go camping with. I don't want to go camping with Dwight. Just too intense. I also think I would not want to go camping with Jim, doesn't he seem like not a great camper? You know who I think I would want to go camping with is maybe, hear me out, Roy. Doesn't Roy seem like he's going to carry a lot of heavy shit and he's going to put up the tent? Doesn't he say like maybe he's a good outdoorsman? I think if a bear came along, he's definitely getting in the middle of me and a bear. Like, I trust that. Yeah, I feel like Roy has gone
我想过我不想和谁去露营。我不想和德怀特去露营。太激进。我还觉得我不想和吉姆去露营，他不觉得是个不太好的露营者吗？你知道我觉得我想和谁去露营吗，听我说完，罗伊。罗伊难道不像是那种会扛很多重物、会搭帐篷的人吗？难道他不像是那种擅长户外活动的人吗？我觉得如果熊来了，他绝对会挡在我跟熊中间。这点我信他。对，我觉得罗伊经常跟他的
hunting with his like cousins and stuff, like has a deer stand somewhere. I mean, the downside is he's probably drinking late into the night. But the other person I was going to say that I would go camping with is Karen. I think Karen would be super fun to camp with. Oh, interesting. You know, she's smart. She's funny. We would have similar interests. We'd go hiking, but then we would have a little rosé by the fire in the evening. I just, I feel like that would be like a really good vibe. And finally, my last group of people I would want to go camping with in real life, in real life, like Jenna has now gone camping with Roy and Karen.
表兄弟之类的人去打猎，在某处有个鹿架。缺点是，他可能会喝酒喝到很晚。不过我要说的另一个人，我会和她去露营的是凯伦。我觉得和凯伦一起露营会超级有趣。哦，有意思。你知道的，她很聪明。她很有趣。我们会有共同的兴趣。我们会去远足，然后傍晚在火堆旁喝点桃红葡萄酒。我只是觉得那会是一种非常棒的氛围。最后，我在现实生活中想一起去露营的最后一群人，在现实生活中，就像珍娜现在已经和罗伊还有凯伦去过露营一样。
I would also go camping me and Lee with Michael and Holly. I would go couples camping with Michael. I would. I think they'd be fun. I mean, Michael in his just like childlike, wonder of the world, I think could be fun to camp with and entertaining. I mean, three days is a long time. I think they would do a lot of voices.
我和李也会和迈克尔还有霍莉去露营。我会和迈克尔一起去情侣露营。我会的。我觉得他们会很有趣。我是说，迈克尔那种孩子般对世界的好奇心，我觉得和他露营会很有趣，也很搞笑。我的意思是，三天是很长的一段时间。我觉得他们会模仿很多不同的声音。
Yeah, I think on like day two when they're going like, I like a piece of picat, I. You're right. And they're like doing all their voices. Maybe it's too much. Yeah, three days is a bit much. But I got to jump in here, Jenna. I'm so sorry. What is it? Well, first of all, Roy, like, first of all, you have to hang out with Roy for three days.
对，我觉得到了第二天，当他们说“我喜欢一块皮卡派，我……”。你说得对。他们一直在模仿各种声音。也许有点过头了。对，三天确实有点久。不过我得插话了，珍娜。非常抱歉。怎么了？首先，罗伊，首先，你得和罗伊一起待三天。
Yeah. what are you going to talk about with Roy? And number two, you just talked about how Roy would defend you from a bear. You have Rain Wilson on your show. And you're talking about how Roy would be the best one to defend you from a bear. Are you kidding me? Okay. Here's the thing. Come on. I'm offended. I'm deeply offended. I need someone who will defend me from a bear, but also be pleasant to camp with. So I feel like, yes, Dwight will protect me, but am I going to enjoy the rest of the three days? No. He's, going to have me up at like 4.45 a.m. on some expedition, some quest. Like, no, Roy is sleeping in. And also, if Roy doesn't talk to me, who cares? I'll read a book. You know what I mean? I think Karen's a good way to go because interesting conversationalist. Pretty chill, but capable. Exactly. She'll help carry stuff from the car. Smart. Yep. All right. Well, I'm going to throw something at you guys. Okay. I would go camping with Joe Bennett. Really? because I think she goes full glamping.
对。你要和罗伊聊什么？第二，你刚刚说罗伊会保护你免受熊的袭击。你的节目里可是有雷恩·威尔逊的。而你却在说罗伊会是保护你免受熊袭击的最佳人选。你在开玩笑吧？好吧。事情是这样的。拜托。我被冒犯了。我深受打击。我需要一个既能保护我免受熊袭击，又能让露营变得愉快的人。所以我觉得，是的，德怀特会保护我，但我会享受剩下的三天吗？不会。他会让我早上4点45分起床去进行某种远征、某种探险。不，罗伊会睡懒觉。而且，如果罗伊不跟我说话，谁在乎呢？我会看书。你知道我的意思吗？我觉得凯伦是个不错的人选，因为她是个有趣的聊天对象。挺随性，但很有能力。没错。她会帮忙把东西从车上搬下来。很聪明。没错。好吧，那我要抛出一个想法给你们。好吧。我会和乔·贝内特去露营。真的吗？因为我觉得她会搞全套的豪华露营。
And I don't want to poop in the woods, okay? I want some type of like fashion toilet situation. Dwight is a survivalist, no doubt about it. He can build a structure. He can do the things. I don't want to wipe with a leaf, you know? I don't want any of that. But I feel like Joe Bennett, she would have a staff that would go ahead of us and set up the tent.
我可不想在树林里拉屎，好吗？我想要某种高档的马桶设施。德怀特是个生存主义者，毫无疑问。他能盖建筑。他能搞定各种事。我可不想用树叶擦屁股，你知道吗？我才不要那些。但我觉得乔·贝内特，她会带一个团队走在我们前面把帐篷搭好。
And like we'd probably have like these really nice chairs by the fire. I want to glamp with Joe Bennett. That's what I want to do. For three days. She'd probably use her dogs as pack animals. Yes. We would ride her dogs. We're not very tall. Yeah, you're small enough. You'd be on one dog. The other dog would be carrying your toilet and your toilet paper. Yeah, please. So you don't have to use a leaf and a log. I don't want to use a leaf in a log. That sounds horrible. And then in real life, I think Creed Bratton would be a blast to go camping with. You guys, he goes fishing with his son. Also, he's obsessed with the TV show alone. He turned me and Josh onto it. Like, we've gone over
而且我们大概还会有非常舒适的椅子摆在火堆旁。我想和乔·贝内特一起去豪华露营。这就是我想做的事。为期三天。她可能会把她的狗当成驮兽。对。我们会骑着她的狗。我们个子不高。对，你个子够小。你会坐在一条狗上。另一条狗会驮着你的马桶和卫生纸。对，拜托。这样你就不用树叶和木头了。我才不想用树叶和木头。听起来太可怕了。然后在现实生活中，我觉得和克里德·布拉顿一起露营一定会嗨翻天。你们知道的，他会和儿子一起去钓鱼。而且，他对电视节目《独自一人》着迷得不行。他把我和乔希也拉入坑了。所以，我们曾去
and watched it with him. So, like, I know that Creed knows how to, like, probably by this point, trap a rabbit. Hook a fish. Build a shelter. He can definitely fish. He's very good at fishing. And, you know, he would have campfire songs and crazy-ass stories that you wouldn't know, are these true or not? You know, he can spin a yarn. I think that's a great answer. And Creed is always the best dance. Whenever I go to like fan events or something and someone's like, who would you rather blah, blah, blah with? I just throw Creed in there because I give Creed some love and he's so fascinating. But you're right. You would have three hours guaranteed entertainment every night at the campfire with Creed, no doubt. Songs, stories, monologues, dances. He also does yoga every day.
他那里和他一起看。所以，我敢肯定克里德到这个时候已经知道怎么捕兔子了。钓鱼。搭避难所。他绝对会钓鱼。他钓鱼非常厉害。而且，你知道的，他会讲营火歌和一些疯狂透顶的故事，让你分不清真假。你知道的，他很会瞎编。我觉得这真是个绝佳的答案。而且克里德总是最佳舞者。每当我参加粉丝活动之类的事情，有人问“你宁愿和谁谁谁去……”时，我都会直接把克里德抛出去，因为我得给克里德点爱，而且他太迷人了。但你说得对。跟克里德在一起，你每天晚上在营火旁都能保证有三个小时的绝对娱乐。唱歌、讲故事、独白、跳舞。他每天还做瑜伽。
So he would probably like bust out some yoga that we would all do in the morning. And he takes naps. I'm all for a nap. He goes to bed early. I think this is a really good camping partner. Wow. I don't think there's a better answer than Creed in real life. Yeah. He'd be so tickled too.
所以他早上可能会突然来一段瑜伽，让我们大家一起练。而且他会睡午觉。我双手赞成睡午觉。他睡得早。我觉得这绝对是个极好的露营伙伴。哇。我觉得在现实生活中不会有比克里德更好的答案了。对。他也会乐坏的。
Is there like a prize for this? Does she win? Does she have a prize? Wait, do I win a signed threat level midnight poster by John Christop? You do. You do. I want to throw something out there. I want to go away from the cast for camping because you've convinced me on Creed, but otherwise,
这有什么奖品吗？她赢了吗？她有什么奖品吗？等等，我能赢得一张由约翰·克里斯托普签名的“威胁级别：午夜”海报吗？你可以的。你可以的。我想提出一个想法。我想把露营的人选排除在演员之外，因为你已经说服我选克里德了，除此之外，
I don't really want to go camping with any action. actor because I just, I'm sorry. Jenna, how dare you? How dare you? We would have so much fun. We might. We might. But we're all getting eaten by the bears.
我其实不想和任何演员去露营，因为我，抱歉。珍娜，你怎么敢？你怎么敢？我们会玩得很开心的。也许吧。也许吧。但我们都会被熊吃掉的。
Rain, I've always said that Jenna and I should do an amazing race. We'd be horrible. I would love to see you guys on an amazing race. That's a great idea. For real. You'd be so good. Who is doing the physical challenges? Who's like ziplining down the side of the mountain between me and Angela?
雷恩，我一直说珍娜和我应该去参加《极速前进》。我们会烂透了。我很想看你们俩去《极速前进》。这真是个好主意。说真的。你们一定会表现得很棒。谁来做体力挑战？我和安吉拉之间，谁来从山崖边上玩高空滑索？
And I don't like. to eat weird things, Rain. If they say one of us has to eat like an ostrich egg to win, that's not happening. I can't. Is that happen an amazing race? Sometimes. Every once in a while, you have to eat like a scorpion or something. Are you eating a scorpion, rain? Yeah, I'd eat a scorpion. I went on bare grills. That's right. Wilderness. What's bear grills? Wilderness. Are you kidding, it's so good. It's like he's a crazy, amazing, like, surviving. guy and Rain went on it and so did Ed. Oh, you have to watch it. Rain, did you like it? What was that experience like? I had a blast. But yeah, Bear Grills is this survivalist, former like,
而且我不喜欢。吃奇怪的东西，雷恩。如果他们说我们俩必须吃鸵鸟蛋才能赢，那可不行。我做不到。《极速前进》里真的有这出吗？偶尔。偶尔你得吃蝎子之类的心。你会吃蝎子吗，雷恩？会啊，我会吃蝎子。我去过贝尔·格里尔斯的节目。没错。荒野求生。什么是贝尔·格里尔斯？荒野。开玩笑吗，太棒了。他是个疯狂、厉害的求生专家，
UK Marine guy and he's a great TV host and it's called Running Wild, I think, is the show. And yeah, we went out into the Utah wilderness. But the scariest thing about doing it was he strapped me to a helicopter. So when I got picked up by the helicopter, I had to ride on the skids on the outside of the helicopter and I was chained and we were zooming 100, 200 feet over the trees at like 50 miles an hour. And I have a fear of heights and it was brutal. But worse than that, when I got picked up at the end of it, they lowered a winch with a
雷恩去过，艾德也去过。哦，你们一定要看。雷恩，你喜欢吗？那是个什么样的体验？我玩得很开心。不过，贝尔·格里尔斯是个生存专家，曾任职于英国海军陆战队，他是个很棒的电视主持人，那个节目好像叫《荒野求生》。是的，我们去了犹他州的荒野。但做这件事最吓人的地方在于他把我绑在直升机上。所以当我被直升机吊起来时，我不得不坐在直升机外面的起落架上，我被拴着，我们在大约50英里每小时的速度下，在树梢上方100、200英尺的高度呼啸而过。我有恐高症，那太残酷了。但比这更糟糕的是，当我最后被接走时，他们放下一个带缆绳的绞盘，
cable and then they dragged me up into the air. So I was dangling by 100 feet under a helicopter and then it took off over the mountains. That was nuts. That was absolutely nuts. I think I might have had a bowel movement of some kind because that's just what is going through your mind right then? Yeah. How do you get through that?
然后把我拉到空中。所以我被悬挂在直升机下方100英尺的高空，然后它飞越了群山。那太疯狂了。简直太疯狂了。我想我当时可能失禁了，因为那正是你脑子里飞速闪过的念头？对。你是怎么挺过去的？
It goes beyond terror where you're just like, okay, I guess I'm going to die and there's not really anything I can do. I mean... This is how I go out. I guess this is it. This is it. and you're just flying around, and you're just going one breath at a time. And it was absolutely brutal.
那种感觉超越了恐惧，你只会想，“好吧，我想我要死了，我也无能为力。”我是说……我要在这结束了。我想就是这样。就是这样。然后你在空中飞来飞去，只能一次呼吸一次呼吸地撑过去。那绝对太残酷了。
It was brutal. But we did, that made the cliff climbing, and I ate rot grubs. And, you know, I did a cold plunge in an alpine lake at like dawn and a zip line. That was all cakewalk compared to being strapped to a helicopter. The grubs thing was so gross. I mean, it's so gross to me. Like, I would have puked. They taste like people.
太残酷了。不过我们确实爬了悬崖，我还吃了树根虫。而且，你知道的，我在黎明时分的高山湖泊里洗了冰水澡，还玩了高空滑索。跟被绑在直升机上比起来，这些都是小菜一碟。虫子的事情太恶心了。我是说，对我来说太恶心了。我会吐出来的。它们尝起来像人肉。
Peanut butter. Really? Yeah, the grubs, little grubs taste like peanut butter. Yeah. All grubs taste like peanut butter? You've had more than one type of growth? Are they protein forward? Because I'm really looking to up my protein.
花生酱。真的吗？对，那些虫子，小虫子尝起来像花生酱。真的吗？所有的虫子都尝起来像花生酱吗？你吃过不止一种虫子吗？它们富含蛋白质吗？因为我真的很想补充蛋白质。
You are not eating grubs, Jenna. I think it's the future. It's, you could have a grub farm. Talk to Creed. I think he grows his own. He grows his own rot grubs. He's got a little thing on his patio. I want to pitch something.
你才不吃虫子呢，珍娜。我觉得这是未来。你可以开个虫子养殖场。去跟克里德聊聊。我觉得他自己养。他自己养树根虫。他在露台上有个小地方。我想提个建议。
Maybe the two of you should go on Amazing Race, Not me and... Oh, Rain and Green and Angela. What? Angela, why are me and you going on Amazing Race together when you partner with Rain and he'll eat all the grubs and he'll do all the stunts? What am I breaking? You're reading the map and you're like keeping things positive. You just didn't look good, babe.
也许你们两个应该去参加《极速前进》，而不是我和……哦，雷恩和克里德还有安吉拉。什么？安吉拉，为什么我和你要一起去参加《极速前进》，而你却和雷恩搭档，然后他会吃掉所有的虫子，包揽所有的特技？我负责什么？你负责看地图，还要保持乐观的心态。你看起来可不太好，宝贝。
Oh, thanks, babe. Yeah. Yeah. Wow. You guys would be a good team. You would. It would be very entertaining. It'd be such a...
哦，谢谢你，宝贝。对。对。哇。你们俩会是个好搭档。真的会。那一定会非常……
hot mess. Rain would call me like a cousin fucker and we'd run out a diet Coke. What if the accountants went on the amazing race? What if we all teamed up with our love interests and we competed against each other? So you've got Steve and Amy, got the two of you, me and John team up. Who else have we got, Mindy and BJ? We've got Oscar and the senator. Oscar and the senator, yes. Maybe Craig and David Denman could be a team. Oh, wait. What have been? about Hunter and Jan. Yes, Hunter and Malora. There we go.
一团糟。雷恩会叫我“表亲操者”，然后我们的健怡可乐会喝光。如果会计们去参加《极速前进》会怎么样？如果我们都和自己的恋爱对象组队，然后互相竞争呢？所以你有史蒂夫和艾米，你们俩，我和约翰组队。我们还有谁，明迪和比尔·杰？我们有奥斯卡和参议员。奥斯卡和参议员，对。也许克雷格和大卫·德曼可以是一队。哦，等等。还有猎人（Hunter）和简（Jan）呢？对，猎人和玛洛拉。这就对了。
You guys, that would kill. Somebody calls CBS. Phyllis and Bob Vance. Yeah. There you go. That's so good. It would be amazing. There it is.
伙计们，那绝对杀疯了。快给哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）打电话。菲利斯和鲍勃·万斯。对。这就对了。太棒了。那就绝了。就是这样。
That would get really good ratings, at least for the first one. You guys, I never got a chance to say who I would go camping with in real life, who isn't a cast member. And I want to say, and I think you're going to agree with me, that it's Randallinehorn. Our DP. Yeah. Oh, yeah. And beloved director. Yeah. Our DP and frequent director, who was a whitewater rafting enthusiast and has traveled the world and
收视率一定会非常高，至少第一期是这样。伙计们，我刚才一直没机会说在现实生活中，如果不是演员的话，我想和谁去露营。我想说，而且我觉得你们会同意我的看法，那就是兰德尔·莱恩霍恩。我们的摄影指导。对。哦，是的。还有我们敬爱的导演。对。我们的摄影指导兼常驻导演，他是个白水漂流爱好者，去过世界各地，
hiked the outback. Yeah. He started on Survivor. In fact, our camera crew, you know, frequent office lady listeners are going to know this, but Matt and Randall are frequent directors and DPs started on Survivor because Greg wanted that immediacy of the cameras capturing the reality of the workers and wanted that that look and feel. And they ended up being just so integral to the look and feel of the show.
在内陆徒步。对。他从《幸存者》开始干起。事实上，我们的摄像团队，熟悉“办公室女士”的听众们都知道这一点，但马特和兰德尔作为常驻导演和摄影指导，都是从《幸存者》开始的，因为格雷格希望摄像机能即时捕捉到工人们的真实状态，想要那种视觉风格和感觉。最后，他们对这部剧的视觉效果和质感起到了至关重要的作用。
But Randall, slam dunk. Thank you. Randall, Sam Dunk. Also, Matt Sone. He hikes up crazy. And he was also like, you know, super outdoorsy camera guy. He's sinewy. I bet he can like get into.
但兰德尔，绝对稳了。谢谢。兰德尔，稳了。还有马特·索恩。他经常去疯狂徒步。而且他也是那种，你知道的，超级热爱户外的摄像师。他很精瘦。我敢打赌他能爬上……
He's sinewy? You know, like he can climb things. And I one time he invited me to go for a hike. This was years ago. And I was like, oh, I'm so tired. I don't know. And then he was hiking. He had his kid, like, who was like toddler size, like in a one of those backpacks that the kid, like, rides in.
他很精瘦？你知道的，就像他能爬各种东西。有一次他邀请我去徒步。那是好几年前的事了。我说，哦，我太累了。我不知道。然后他去徒步时。他还带着他的孩子，差不多是幼儿大小，那种坐在专门的儿童背篓背包里的孩子。
And I was like, yeah, I'm the one being like, I'm kind of tired. And he's like carrying another person on the hike. He should have put you in the backpack. No, you know, just like Dwight and Angela. Your American doll size. That's what we do an amazing race is we have like a kid's backpack and I carry you. Yes. The entirety of the amazing race.
而我才是那个一路叫着“我有点累”的人。而他却在徒步时背着另一个人。他应该把你塞进背包里。不，你知道的，就像德怀特和安吉拉那样。你长得像美国女孩洋娃娃一样大。我们在《极速前进》里要做的就是弄个儿童背包，然后我背着你。对。整场《极速前进》都这样。
That's it. And I like have like water with a long straw that. I like feed you as we go. Yeah. Camelback. Yeah. Yeah. I think you just urinate into a satchel, kind of like in Dune, and then the urine is processed
就是这样。而且我还要带那种带长吸管的水。边走边喂你喝。对。骆驼背水袋。对。对。我觉得你只要尿在一个小包里，有点像《沙丘》里的那样，然后尿液被处理成水，
into water, and that's what I drink. I'm essentially drinking your urine. It's all recyclable, you guys. That's amazing. So smart. You never have to rest. Just like in Dune. I bet you guys haven't even seen Dune, have you?
那就是我喝的东西。我基本上是在喝你的尿。这一切都是可循环利用的，伙计们。太棒了。太聪明了。你根本不需要休息。就像在《沙丘》里一样。我敢打赌你们甚至都没看过《沙丘》，对吧？
Of course I have. Are you crazy? I have, I have, like, teenagers. Dune is so good, Jen. Is it like Star Wars? Doon 2 is even better. No. Oh, like, Dune 2 was fantastic.
我当然看过了。你疯了吗？我看过，我看过，我有青少年。珍娜，《沙丘》太棒了。它像《星球大战》吗？《沙丘2》甚至更好。不。哦，就像《沙丘2》简直绝了。
It was so good. I tried to watch it and it was like 20 minutes of just, it was just so slow moving and sand and I didn't understand anything. Oh my God. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Who was the woman who hosted the Golden Globes, Nikki Glazier? Yeah.
太好看了。我试着看了一下，结果差不多有20分钟全是，全是节奏缓慢的沙子，我什么也没看懂。天哪。我很抱歉。我很抱歉。主持金球奖那个女的是谁，妮基·格拉泽？对。
Did you see her mind? Did she not like June? Did she say the same thing? Oh my God. Her monologue is so funny. When you're done with this, go watch Nikki Glazer's monologue. It is so funny. Does she go off one, too?
你看到她的段子了吗？她是不是不喜欢《沙丘》？她是不是也这么说了？哦，天哪。她的独白太搞笑了。等你看完这个，去看看妮基·格拉泽的独白。太搞笑了。她是不是也吐槽了一部？
But she goes like, Hans Zimmer is here. Congratulations at Hans Zimmer because he did the soundtrack up to Dune. And she's like, my favorite song of yours is the one that goes, she's very funny. Oh, man. Get her on office ladies. We should. Yeah. Nikki, come on. All right, so everyone, we're going to watch Rain's Bear Grills and Eds, and now we're going to watch Nikki's opening monolog.
但她是这么说的，“汉斯·齐默来了。恭喜汉斯·齐默，因为他为《沙丘》做了配乐。”然后她说，“我最喜欢你的歌是那首……”，她真的太搞笑了。哦，天哪。快让妮基上“办公室女士”。我们应该这么做。对。妮基，来吧。好吧，各位，我们要去看雷恩的《荒野求生》和艾德的节目，现在我们要去看妮基的开场独白了。
And Dune 1 and 2. And why not watch Rain's new movie that's out on Hulu called Code 3? Code 3. Okay, I've seen Rain's new movie Code 3, and it's excellent, Rain. It's truly excellent, and you're so good in it. It's so funny, but it's more than funny. And here's my pitch. If you like the TV show The Pit, this is the paramedic version of the pit, but also funnier. Yeah. So it's like comedic, the pit, but paramedics. That is a great pitch, Jenna. I want to watch that. Rain, I'm sorry.
还有《沙丘1》和《沙丘2》。为什么不顺便看看雷恩在Hulu上热播的新电影《代号3》呢？代号3。好吧，我看过雷恩的新电影《代号3》，非常棒，雷恩。真的非常棒，你在里面演得太好了。非常搞笑，但不仅搞笑。这是我的安利点。如果你喜欢电视剧《急诊室的故事》，这就是急诊室的急救员版本，但更好笑。所以它就像喜剧版的急救室，但主角是急救员。这安利真棒，珍娜。我想看那个。雷恩，对不起。
It's in my cue. I'm sorry. It's a whole day. It's like one shift, one long shift as a paramedic. Your character's last shift, you're going to get out of the paramedic life, and I won't say anymore. And I'm training a new rookie paramedic. Yeah.
它在我的待播列表里。对不起。那是一整天。就像是急救员的一个长班。你角色的最后一个班，你就要离开急救员生涯了，我不能剧透更多了。而且我在带一个急救员新人。对。
Who is great. Who is that actress? She's great. Amy Carrero. Amy Carrero. The whole cast is great. Lowrell Howrie. Rob Wrigal.
她太棒了。那个女演员是谁？她太棒了。艾米·卡雷罗。艾米·卡雷罗。整个演员阵容都很棒。罗尔·豪瑞。罗伯·里格尔。
There's an office connection. Rob Riggle. Captain, what's his name? Captain Bob? Captain Bob. Captain Jack. Captain Jack. Captain Jack.
这里有个办公室的梗。罗伯·里格尔。队长，他叫什么名字？鲍勃队长？杰克队长。杰克队长。杰克队长。
Rob Riggle plays a really assholy doctor in the emergency room. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Well, everybody, go see Code 3. folks are loving it. And, Rain, thank you so much
罗伯·里格尔在急诊室里演了一个非常混蛋的医生。好吧。对。好吧，各位，快去看《代号3》。大家都非常喜欢。而且，雷恩，非常感谢你
for being on Friday chit chat with us. I love you guys so much. This has been such a pleasure. Thanks for having me. We love you. Yay. You have to come back for...
来参加我们的“周五闲聊”。我太爱你们了。这真是太棒了。谢谢你们邀请我。我们爱你。耶。你得回来……
Shut up. Shut up. Jenna F. already commented how much she loved this episode. Yes. She wrote in. And she said,
闭嘴。闭嘴。珍娜·F已经评论说她有多喜欢这一集了。对。她写信来了。她说，
I love this episode so much. She said... Oh, look. Here's a new comment from Crean B. Creasy. He says, yes, I do have grubs. Angela Kay has also hearted this and given it a thumbs up and a little lady running in the red dress. So she really enjoyed this episode.
我太喜欢这一集了。她说……哦，看。这是克里德·B（Crean B）的新评论。他说，是的，我确实有虫子。安吉拉·K也给这条动态点了个心和竖起的大拇指，还有一个穿着红裙子奔跑的小人表情包。所以她真的很喜欢这一集。
Nice use of emojis. All right, everyone. Come back, Rain. Come back anytime. Love you. Bye. Bye, guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
表情符号用得不错。好了，各位。常来，雷恩。随时欢迎回来。爱你们。再见。再见，伙计们。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”是Audyssey出品的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·贝格尔。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audyssey 执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“办公室女士”由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertry》。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。